in this lesson you're gonna learn how to
draw an angle in radians in standard
position or sometimes refer to as
sketching an angle in standard position
but we're gonna do it in radians which
might be new to you you might be used to
degrees now all of a sudden they're
teachers saying we're working with
radians the main thing to remember
though is that PI radians that's the
same thing as 180 degrees so whatever
you see PI you can replace that with 180
degrees now when we draw an angle in
standard position we have what we call
the initial ray that's where it's kind
of like a spinner like imagine if you
were like spinning this it's going to
either rotate counterclockwise or it's
gonna rotate clockwise now if it rotates
counterclockwise we refer to that as a
positive angle if it rotates clockwise
that's actually a negative angle it's a
little counterintuitive now the main
thing is you want that initial ray along
the positive x axis and then wherever
the ray or the spinner ends up that's
what we call the terminal ray that's
where it terminates your stops and then
we just draw an arrow showing the
direction whether we were going
counterclockwise or clockwise now some
angles and radians that are good
remember they come up a lot are like PI
over six that's equal to 30 degrees
because remember pi is 180 180 divided
by six is thirty another one that's good
to remember is PI over four that's 45
degrees again 180 divided by four PI
over three that's sixty degrees because
180 divided by three PI over two that's
90 degrees and we can have multiples of
these but the main thing here is is that
you want to think about like for example
PI over six what this is it's like
taking PI which is like 180 degrees and
you're dividing up into six portions
like one two three four five six right
like six pizza slices and so if we were
going let's say for example two PI over
six that means you're going one two
you'd end up right there and so this is
our initial ray this is our terminal
rate and that's how we would draw it let
me show you some examples I think it'll
get clearer as we go through this say
for example number one 25 PI over six
how would you sketch that
the first thing you want to do is want
to draw our initial ray okay along that
positive x-axis and then what I like to
do especially when it's an improper
fraction is turn it into a mixed number
so six goes into 25 how many times four
with one left over so that's really like
4 and 1/6 pi well we know that pi is a
hundred and eighty degrees so that's
gonna be like 1 PI 2 pi 3 pi C I'm going
half a revolution 4 pi
and now we're gonna go one six of Pi so
one sixth of this half revolution which
is going to be right about there now
it's helpful to remember that PI over
six is thirty so you know what 30
degrees is you can go just a little bit
you know past and you've got it now we
have our arrow to show the direction of
rotation and that will help as well
let's look at number two now so number
two we have negative seven PI over three
so first thing I would do is convert
this into a mixed number three goes into
seven twice with one left over so this
is really like negative 2 and 1/3 pi
negative means we're going clockwise
right let's start over here at the
positive x-axis that's our initial rate
we're going 1 pi 2 pi and now we're
going that would be 3 pi but we're just
going 1/3 of the way we know that pi
over 3 C 1/3 pi is the same as PI over
you know that's a 60-degree angle so
we're going like about 60 degrees more
and that's our terminal race so we
basically went one revolution plus
another 60 degrees
okay last example see if you can get
this one 19 PI over 4 4 goes into 19 how
many times 4 times with 3 left over so
that's really like 4 and 3/4 pi this is
positive so remember when it's positive
we're going counterclockwise so we're
gonna go 1 PI 2 pi 3 PI 4 PI and now 3/4
of pi well another PI would put us all
over here at 180 degrees but we're going
3 quarters of the way which is going to
be right about there and you've got it
if you want to learn more about radians
I did a more comprehensive
that's a video about what a Radian is
and how to work with radians and
coterminal angles and reference angles
and more follow me over to that video
right there
and we'll go over that there